durant l'été à new york l'animation
n'est pas forcément dans les rues mais
plutôt sur les toits des immeubles et
terrasson très prisé par une clientèle
plutôt privilégié il faut dire que la
vie y est spectaculaire à vous d'en
juger pascal golomer tristan lebrun un
bain d'eau fraîche
rien de très original dès que l'été
s'installe à moins de prendre de la
hauteur
la piscine avec vue sur manhattan
c'est tellement plus chic et à 30 $
l'entrée les new yorkais en raffolent
comme ils raffolent d'ailleurs de toutes
les terrasses cette vue imprenable sur
le fond du queensboro par exemple
réservé aux membres d'un club de sport
qui a installé ici son terrain de tennis
et puis il ya la terrasse version plus
culturel le metropolitan museum propose
sur son toit de découvrir un verre à la
main
les sculptures de l'artiste américain
roy lichtenstein
mais pour capter l'attention des
visiteurs la concurrence est rude
quand central park s'étend à vos piles
c'est magnifique cette vue panoramique
tout le monde veut venir ici mais la
terrasse peut aussi devenir un havre de
nature terrain d'expérimentation pour
leslie et ses amis écologie ici vous
avez un mélange de fleurs de la lavande
de la sauge aussi et le sol est
spécialement étudié pour retenir la
pluie c'est très joli et en plus c'est
utile sur un toit normale en plein été
la température peut monter jusqu'à 75
degrés avec cette végétation
la température ne dépasse pas 25 donc
cela réduira la consommation d'énergie
nécessaire pour la fin dit cioni rima
bhl et réduira aussi la température
ambiante dans la ville mais point
d'esprit civique la terrasse à new york
c'est d'abord et avant tout un signe
extérieur de réussite
le lieu de fête idéal pour les longues
soirées d'été à partager avec les amis
sans modération